hey google
define babel
a confused noise typically that made by
a number of voices
all right then this is google babble
explained
[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and let's
say i get a google talk message on my
phone my android phone as i'm walking
into my apartment i answer the message
and i start having a conversation with
this person and then i put my phone down
and i'm done with the conversation and
then i open up my tablet and i have a
new notification an unread message but i
already read that message it's already
completed the conversation on my phone
that's fine i swipe to clear that
message but then i go back to my
computer and i have a gmail tab open and
i have another unread notification from
google talk of the same completed
conversation that is just one of the
problems google has with their messaging
platform but the real problem right now
is that google has multiple chat
services multiple messaging and instant
messaging services and that's the real
problem is because they don't talk to
each other their notifications don't
sync you can read a conversation on one
and you have to pick every single time
you want to chat with someone how you
want to communicate with them do you
want to use google talk do you want to
use google voice do you want to use
google plus messenger do you want to use
gmail what do you want to use you want
to use a google plus hangout how do you
communicate with this person it's a bit
of a mess right now so babel is the
expected service that google will use to
essentially brand these all into one
social messaging platform that basically
replaces all the ones that currently
exist it's a pretty smart idea it may
seem like a minor thing but i'm
expecting this to be a pretty solid
thing pretty big chunk of what google
talks about at google i o this year in
2013. so what's battle going to be like
what are the features going to be like
well the number one expected feature is
it's going to have a unified user
interface across every single platform
so it's kind of a mess already right now
for example with google talk you notice
the way it looks on the desktop you use
a google talk conversation in google
plus it'll have a direct link to a
hangout and it'll have a bunch of
different google plus related things but
if you use it in a gmail tab it looks
different from that and if you use it on
your android phone it looks even
different from that and also knows
google plus messenger is totally
separate randomly inside of the google
plus app tucked away in there doesn't
talk to any other services for some
reason so they all look different and
they all don't talk to each other so
google babble along with unifying all
the different messaging services into
one core service it'll all look the same
so you know it's the same service number
two is that everything is expected to
sync and talk to each other so babble on
every single platform will notify itself
and if you pick up a conversation on
your tablet the notification will
disappear from every other device that
you own that has babylon and number
three expect video chat expect google
plus hangouts to be very tightly
integrated and expect your whole google
plus account to be very tightly
integrated into this service after all
it is google making it and google
already has a pretty good idea of how to
build and integrate things with each
other that it already controls so expect
google plus hangouts expect a button
inside of babel to directly take you to
a video chat that will end up being a
google plus hangout in fact it might
even be called google plus babel but i
wouldn't put money on that but again
expect the chat hangout feature to be
there and lastly number four expect a
bunch of little improvements for example
in the clients we use today like google
talk and google plus messenger there are
a bunch of little hiccups and quirks
with for example group messaging so
expect some improvements there there is
also said to be more than 800 emojis and
emoticons so sources close to it are
pretty confident this is going to be a
pretty well-built system and also things
like sending pictures and maybe videos
and small files the way you can with
skype now so it's really taking on the
bulk of all the different services we
have today all at once now apple will be
most successful and be able to separate
itself from other services similar to
this which i'll get to in a second if
it's available everywhere and google's
pretty good at that right now it kind of
covers all its bases even though they
don't overlap but if babel is available
everywhere we can expect to see it right
off the bat in ios on android with a
chrome app with a windows app with an os
10 app and with a web app and that way
it'll pretty much cover the majority of
people who are going to be using the
service there's no talk really about a
blackberry os or windows phone app yet
but hey you never know that could be a
priority later now google's not blind to
the competition what is the difference
between this and imessage because
imessage is basically apple's equivalent
of this well the main difference is it's
availability right now i can't use
imessage if i don't have a mac or some
sort of ios device so if you have an
ipad or an iphone or a mac you can use
imessage and talk to your other friends
who have those same devices but there's
no web client so your windows buddies
won't be able to talk to you on imessage
and it kind of talks to your sms as well
so that's nice if you have an iphone but
the idea of babel is to be able to use
it
everywhere on every single device even
if you have a windows phone you can go
and log into your browser and continue
conversations there the same way you'd
be able to with gmail so overall babel
may seem like a minor thing at first but
i've gotten so many questions about it
that it's turned out to be a pretty
major thing in my mind as we approach
when can we expect to see it i would
expect to see it alongside the next or
latest version of android key lime pie
at google i o this year so just a couple
of weeks away from that and expect it
it's pretty much imminent now almost the
name is basically confirmed we've seen
leaked screenshots of the user interface
and little dialog boxes that have been
popping up on people's screens by
accident so it's pretty much confirmed
that it's going to be called babel
b-a-b-e-l
uh so if you guys are wondering it's
just around the corner and we should be
seeing it sometime very soon so that's
it just a quick video talking about
google babble again if you like videos
like this definitely be sure to hit that
like button below and the subscribe
button if you want to see more and uh
hopefully we'll get some pretty awesome
videos coming this week and next there
are some awesome
awesome videos coming up i can just tell
you that guarantee it either way thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one
peace and if you want bonus points
google throw chat heads in there
[Music]
you